I will be talking about my current
environment for web development I will
be talking about what text editor I'm
using and what terminal and what shall
I'm using because I experienced in in
many in many talks after the meetups
that people are constantly discussing
what they are using and what would be
good and advantages and disadvantages of
all the text editors
so I just quickly going to show you my
setup and afterwards we can have a
collective discussion but what you are
using and what's best so I'm using
Visual Studio code and I term you can
see here is Visual Studio code and here
is I turn how many of you are using
Visual Studio code okay that's a lot
yeah so I I tried many many text editors
I tried at home Visual Studio webstorm
brackets and ultimately I ended up with
wishes to decode yes I was really amazed
when I was using Visual Studio that
there is a thing like intelligence and
for c-sharp development you have to use
basically Visual Studio and so I tried
with Studio code and I'm happy ever
since and I'm also going to talk about I
term the terminal I use because the
basic terminal is bash I think or it's
called terminal something like this
however I will not spend much time here
because I'm not using it that that often
and also wishes through the code comes
with a terminal on its own yes I think
that's it
another important information is that
I'm using a Mac MacBook Pro and yeah so
the first thing I want to talk about is
Weaver studio code and the features are
displayed here if you click on the link
here you should go to the home page
which is not this plate doesn't matter
we'll just copy it
or will even or even yeah we even just
open it here and show you
they should work right now yeah so so as
I'm working on here I'm going for Visual
Studio code and here are the main
features displayed first of all the
house it has intelligence which is
practically just syntax highlighting and
also autocomplete I was very amazed when
Irene caught encountered this feature it
basically allows you to suggest you the
methods of objects or functions whatever
and I will afterward show a short
showcase on how to use it and then it
will be clear and much easier to
understand
there's also debugging involved in
Visual Studio code you don't need to
debug in Chrome or whatever browser you
are using
you have also built in good comments and
it's ultimately easy to extend extend
but I think nowadays most of the editors
are easy to extend I also created or
even wrote an article about about the
Visual Studio code extensions I'm using
and this is actually the article it has
which pretty much good success I've just
listed all my extensions I'm using I'm
using extensions for HTML like out too
close tag rename tag HTML snippets
markdown extensions of course JavaScript
extensions this is very important
debugger for Chrome you can easily start
debugging without a lot of configuration
maybe I can show you that as well of
course is lint linting checking your
code yes in modules intelligence so if
you if you're interested just go to the
article and check out the extensions
they are pretty nice for developing yes
that's the article about extensions
and the next thing I want to show you is
I term is anyone using our term okay one
awesome then just a short and quick
introduction to our terms just give you
an overview just typing in AI term and
it should be the first one it's a
terminal especially for Mac OS and if I
go to features you can see what what you
can do with with I term you can split
panes you have hot key windows you can
search for stuff you can autocomplete
yeah so different features that makes
the use of of a terminal very easy and
efficient I never really used used the
integrated terminal of Mac OS I started
using item right away because I was
recommended to use it and what was
always happy yes so that's the I term
part and if I go through the
presentation I'm also using it with I
think I will just put it in here because
that's too complicated otherwise I also
combine it with the chat shell is anyone
else using to tell shell one nice I use
it with the oh my oh my Z or however
it's called
it has some nice our teams and features
and also using the out of suggestions
which I'll show you in in practice as
well there's also a good article and it
will show the slides afterwards so you
can check that out as well since my
setup here is a little bit weird I will
go right away to the demonstration part
created a nice a nice slide here yes so
now I'm going to demonstrate how I'm
using both visual studio code and the I
term just figuring out how to use it
properly here I think the best thing is
to just put it in there and
looking on top so maybe another nice
feature is to use spectacle is someone
using that for Mac OS it's just that you
can switch with your window probably
here it comes on default by yeah but Mac
doesn't have has have something like
this
so spectacle on top the glasses is a
nice tool and that's for free and it's
working great so as you can see here I
can't really stand on the side you know
as you can see here is that's the
terminal I have use used a nice team
with coloring and showing the get status
and I'm currently at the developers
rising repository because I want to
demonstrate how to add stuff to the
homepage so what I can do next at first
or what I want to show you first with
all message and and the tech shell in
general is to show you the LRS allows ya
that comes out of the box and they are a
lot especially a lot with kid that's
very useful this can be very useful you
can see here and for example if I want
to do something it can get status which
is just just and it shows me the current
status of get so what's also very nice
and works well with which is to decode
is now when I'm typing or maybe let's
have it let this if I'm typing yeah
probably so so if I'm typing code dot
there is I've installed it in the path I
can't just open we should studio code
and now it opens of course in my other
window but here it is and here are
having the terminal on my site so I can
always work with the terminal here on
this side and can work with the editor
on this side so what I wanted to
demonstrate now is just to see how
Visual Studio code works you have
options here to show you the folders and
files you have a search you have an own
section for your get stuff you have a
debugger mode and the extensions listed
and it's also very easy to install
install extensions you can just add them
here and here
activate them install them uninstall
them etc what's interesting is also
maybe was a little bit bigger here no
she better know you also have a console
here you have a debug console you have a
terminal depending on what shall you
have installed you can also use the
comments here you see just work working
fine and it's also if you have a linter
or something else installed it displays
all the problems and stuff that is not
working so what I did here is as you
know we have a home page for we are for
developers rising and I just added our
new partner that is we accelerate for
chests and search everything is working
easily we accelerate you can see it just
put in a diff here a diff class this
section here and now it one of the
benefits with Visual Studio code is if
you can you can simply click on the tab
here just show me the working tree here
and show me the difference and its side
by side showing you what you have added
or changed and it's working perfectly on
the side on the side here you even have
a mark where the change in your file is
so if your if you are having a large
file with thousand lines then this
really hops and in this case I quickly
can see okay I have here added a diff so
now what I'm going to do is I use the
terminal I'm not most of the time I'm
using the determinant terminal to use
get stuff because it's just faster so
once again I use the check get status to
check what I've what I've done
now say okay I'm using also allies here
and said okay I using a cookie to commit
with a message and I say just add new
partner partner we accept rate
accelerate it stirs it up correctly yeah
or maybe with a double D can also use it
like oh holy [ __ ] what's that so now
that it says are still something missing
okay I have a logo so just get at all
very easy just and then I can ah what I
also want to show you is the
autocomplete I just go in with that and
it shows me the last the last commit I
did with with a type of message like did
this so I use I just say add yeah new
partners logo awesome I don't want to do
that remove so this is not working what
I'm doing now is just pressing ctrl C to
get out of this whatever it did was have
no idea
so I'm trying it again still just out of
completing it what now it's working
right no true true true true awesome now
it's working and now instead of git push
I set the upstream already so just GP
and now it push us to the master branch
and that's pretty easy we'll also want
to show you is now this one resolvers so
it's it it's connected and knows that
there is there there are no changes and
what I want to do or show you as well
is to go to the Help section and if you
haven't worked with Visual Studio code
you can easily just download it install
it and then you can go to the
hmm interactive playground that is what
I wanted to show you and here we
actually I think this is amazing and I
haven't seen this anywhere else it has
an interactive playground where you can
try to use the features so here is a
interactive playground you can see the
numbers here you can simply do some as
it is explained here you can combine
different keys and for example add
multiple cursors on 10y different stuff
awesome but you can also maybe if I want
to just switch lines or cut multiple
multiply lines can also do that very
easily I can switch them around that's
very easy and also can do is I'm not
quite sure if I've installed this yeah
just on the line going down and adding I
don't know what is this here no idea
maybe I can add another comment hi
that's it awesome and I can also delete
it
cool so that's a great feature and it
just goes through this stuff here what I
want to show you is actually the
intellisense which is amazing here is a
basic express example and what
intellisense allows you to do is if you
type app now and then dot then it should
suggest you things which it doesn't
it does but this is not optimized
because that's the playground doesn't
matter it does what it should do it just
suggests you features and methods that's
not working really in the playground
maybe I'm using it
yeah yeah I don't think it's working
like it should here doesn't matter you
can try it on your own and it hopefully
will work
the airline action of talking about that
refactoring so there is plenty of other
stuff on how to speed up your coding and
I think it's pretty good especially if
you're starting with the free Kirkham
curriculum you have the box where you
write your code inside and at the
beginning it is okay but when you later
have to write longer code I think it's
more and more important to have a good
editor with syntax highlighting and also
suggestions and what I've used in the
curriculum when I was more advanced and
working from the advanced algorithms I
was always writing the stuff inside the
text editor like Adam or we chose to
decode and I think it's just easier to
work with it test it and see if you're
working the algorithm the right way
instead of using the field on the
homepage yeah I think that's it I think
those are the most important things I
just wanted to go through since the
setup is really weird here for me I'm
not going to demonstrate more yes oh
yeah I haven't an introduction or maybe
I can close somewhere is the
presentation yes here's the background
credit for somewhere Taylor from
unsplash
yeah just about me a little bit
co-organized in this meetup with Rob
with Robert and I'm a business law
student I'm working as a front-end
developer currently I'm focusing on
machine learning and also did if anyone
is interested in machine learning I also
did where is that or I even have even
wrote an article actually so find it it
would be nice yeah it's here so if you
if you are whoa
if you're trying to get into machine
learning there's a great course online
it's from Kucera because arrow is also
online learning platform it has very it
has a lot of different courses I think
also in CSS and JavaScript and stuff
like that but I did the machine learning
course and I also wrote tips and tricks
on how to do it I think it takes three
months or something and it's just
amazing so I can also recommend to check
especially this course because the
teacher is amazing but also the platform
Coursera it's amazing
yes this was my setup now we can discuss
your setups or if you have any questions
just feel free to ask thank you very
much
[Applause]